Okay Michael. So here's a quick quiz. So we just tried
to argue that boosting has this annoying habbit of not always
over fitting, but of course something can always over fit. Because
otherwise we just do boosting and we're done, then neither of us
would have jobs. And we don't want that to happen. So
here's a little quiz to see if we can figure out the
circumstances under which boosting might over fit, or tends to over
fit. So here are five possiblities. Let me read them to you.
Tell me if they actually make sense. So
here's possiblity number one, boosting will tend to over
fit if The weak learner that it's boosting
over, always chooses the weakest output that is, it,
among all the hypothesis that it finds that
do better than chance over the training with whatever
given distribution. It always pick the one that is
still nonetheless closest to chance, while still being better.
>> Well, why would it do that?
>> Just to be difficult.
>> Alright, and so you want to know, whether that makes
it over, would [INAUDIBLE] make it over fit? [UNKNOWN] boosting overfit.
>> Okay. Alright.
>> The second one is weak learner actually ends up using...or
the weak leaner itself that boosting is using is in fact
a neural network learner. And just for a little specificity, let's
say this is a neural network that has many many layers and
many many nodes. So, you know, it's a big
powerful neural network, alright? the other option is... Boosting has
a lot of data. So you're trying to learn, your
training data is actually very, very, very large. You have
lots and lots of examples. The fourth case, is that,
the true underlying hypothesis,the true underlying concept, is in fact
non linear. So you can't just draw a line. And
then the fifth case is that we let boosting train
much too long. Whatever that means. Let's just say we let it
train a lot. Not just a thousand iterations but a hundred billion iterations.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Billions and billions of itterations. Okay. You got it?
>> Yeah.
>> Alright. Go.